[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
hello everybody how you doing
this is peter sonos now though here to
give you a little bit of a first look
video a little insight on this beta that
we were given called dune spice wars
now
the game first of all i'd like to say i
was intrigued because i saw some other
streamers playing it
i kind of thought it was interesting how
they brought that type of
rts type game into being more of a city
expansion type game
and i thought that it had a lot of
potential i really wanted to play it i
really wanted to see how it felt
um and then after
after that happened i
ended up requesting the key and i
noticed actually my guild leader uh who
i play warcraft with uh plays the game
all the time and he says it's fantastic
so
uh i said all right i gotta give this
thing a try
so
i'm used to an rts map lasting me
uh i'm talking like star starcraft
warcraft um you know we played iron
harvest um there's multiple different
rts types of games that i've played that
i wanted to
that i've seen a genre from multiple
different um
types of developers hands now
june spice wars first of all
it's pretty it's got some pretty decent
graphics like i said it's still in beta
right now
but it has a couple of different things
uh you can beat your stages in multiple
different ways
you can become the governor of the you
know of dune of the planet
um sorry for being so ignorant to
the specifics of dune i haven't seen the
movies
since the original i didn't see the new
one so i apologize uh i hear the
fantastic and i can't wait to finally
see them
side note that so unless you in this
version of doom spice wars um you can
end up
beating a board in multiple different
ways you know you have your governor you
can become governor you can you have a
whole bunch of different ways to
espionage uh the other the other
factions um you can assassinate them um
you can even starve out the ai in your
area and make sure that they go bankrupt
and
uh there's no longer an issue with that
location now
the reason why i wanted to kind of bring
up the game and talk about it is because
the number one issue
the number one issue i had with the game
was there was
almost no tutorial
and i have played more than my fair
share of rts's and i know how to play
them but this was very very confusing
um i even i even went to the to the
extent to contacting my guild leader
nergal and asking him to see if he can
come in and actually
almost like spot tutor me
on what i'm doing
because i was
clueless
and he came in he explained you know the
different factions
i explained to me you know the the
different ways to win he kind of gave me
the the one-two punch of teaching me how
to do
you know basic things
so that i can kind of complete the game
now
the game itself it starts out very very
slow paced for me
and i think for me personally it is a
very it was a very slow paced
game because it was my first time
playing
so i tried to
complete the game using the governor way
uh which is getting um certain amounts
of votes and then you end up getting put
into office as a governor and then once
your place is the governor you can end
up then you have to hold it for i think
it's like 60 days and then you end up
winning the game
now
it sounds very easy but it's not
um because of uh certain aspects of the
game uh you have to take your time to
get certain points to allow you to
expand faster to allow you to go and uh
expand to the point where
you know you you have enough
cities
to to win
now
i actually did not win that way
um
i actually won by starving out the ai
from having uh not enough uh resources
or i think it might have been that he
got attacked too many times by raiders
and just died
now
i myself um
like i said i i played for i played what
the map once
and it was for over four hours
and i will say it didn't feel like four
hours number one number two i had a
blast
uh my chat was super engaged in asking
questions and trying to help me win
because i've never played before and
because there was no tutorial and
there's very little information on
teaching me how to play they were giving
me lots and lots of tips which i really
thought was nice and effective
and
i thought
that because it has so many different
elements
it made it way more enjoyable
than a normal rts now
i'm just gonna talk about a couple
different things uh when it comes to
comes to the game itself uh first of all
just gonna blitz through you know kind
of like uh almost like a ranking of of
how i thought things were i thought the
graphics were good i thought the
gameplay was was pretty good um once i
understood how to do it and how to play
i thought that the the cityscapes were
fantastic and i think that the
replayability on this is going to be
fantastic because you're going to have
more than one way to beat out your other
competitors
i first started with one other
group of people to play against
now i did that because nurgle
recommended i only do it because the ai
he told me
was super smart
and i can kind of see that even with
just being going against
a normal ai
and the ai raiders because there's a
couple of times where i had to
intercept
the uh the other
ai colony
and then i had to go and airlift
my people
onto another colony
to be able to defend it uh from the
raiders so i had to start really playing
strategically and really really start
getting used to getting a lot of those
things done
and
eventually i ended up getting that
squared away and
worked out really well
so i was very very very very happy with
it
now
once again
uh
the thing that was cool was
you have really really in-depth
technology trees
you have your voting which happens every
couple of
a couple of days i think it's like every
week or something like that maybe maybe
even longer than that um
and that will give you different types
of
pros and cons to your colonies
you're very limited on your troops which
is very interesting when you're trying
to produce
a
what method of attack on certain towns
because your towns you could put militia
in them but if you put mullet but if you
get attacked
you know
and they have six militia you're
supposed to have like you know six or
seven people to be able to defeat them
and get out of there and safely and win
and it became harder and harder to do
that the longer and longer the game
progressed
and that's where you know a lot of the
espionage portions came in because you
could actually kind of
knock out some um you know some spice
from that area or things like that
um
oh
i want to talk to you about the spice
too so you send out your spice
harvesters to be able to essentially get
you your
more capital money
now
you start off essentially with one
spice area where you can go you go in
there and you can collect your spices
you can kind of do your stuff and then
after that what ends up happening is you
know it comes it just goes into a pool
and then after that you know there is a
based on what's happening in the planet
how much spice is being brought up who's
got more spice you actually get to
choose what percentage of your spice
turns into money and how much is surplus
and held
it got to the point where i started
playing smarter
and getting as much spice as possible
and producing a backlog as much as
possible as a spice
so that i can actually decrease the
amount of spice to money ratio and once
i started doing that i started getting
money hand over fists
i started being able to produce my my
military
bases faster
once i was able to get the the plastial
uh you know factories going i mean
there's there's so many different facets
of it um take a look at the video
watch it i'm gonna put little clips in
there
so everyone takes a look and sees you
know different portions of the game
um and uh you know
i'm telling you it was fantastic uh if
you uh really really enjoy you know
watching these types of games uh you
know
or if you want to just check us out
while we're playing other games uh my
name is pete also known as sneldo uh i
am on twitch
seven uh seven days a week
i feel like i'm on 27 days a week i'm on
twitch five this week monday to friday
three to eleven pm every single night um
we specialize in world of warcraft uh we
also play other games throughout the
whole week um like v rising uh we
usually end up playing uh like one day
of just random games uh could it be uh v
rising uh you know we'll play some june
um we got phantom brigade coming uh we
got you know titans of industry we got a
whole bunch of different games coming
out so go ahead and check us out uh hit
that like and follow button here uh you
know
if you have if you want to check me out
like i said it's sneldo that's
s-n-a-l-y-g-o uh tv uh over on twitch uh
i'm on twitter uh you know instagram uh
and discord so if you got any questions
follow me and hit me up i greatly
appreciate everything uh make sure you
go and check out the ironworks podcast
every single sunday and go to
loyaltygaming.net to check out for
gaming news on a daily basis those
writers are fantastic
go ahead and check them out love you all
have a fantastic rest of your week all
right and uh i will see you later bye
everybody
and when it died when the faction died
the landscape card
went neutral and started running around
beating the [ __ ] out of everything um
it's a good problem to have
sir definitely
um
yes
you know
thankfully
the other thing i found is like even if
you get into a pinch you can sometimes
trade items to your enemies
if you make it sweet enough for
like there's been times when i've been
sitting on like like capped out plasteel
and i'll be like here you want some
plastiel for some solari or spice or
something
i need five more regions
i'm sorry ten more regions
i'm trying to be governor yep
you better start pulling your influence
now if you want to win that vote
and then you gotta hold the region for a
while you can't just get it and win
what happens if i just attack the other
guy's main town
i mean if you break through and kill it
you'll win but
it's tough to to break through
it's it's basically its own defenses and
it's thick although it's almost half
dead already that helps
hell at this rate you may well just
outlast him
right
oh [ __ ] look what happened
these jabronis decide to attack like i
thought they would
[Music]
uh
yes
sir
oh i won
i guess he died huh
nice
grass
[Music]
you